nous mettait tout au piquet et quand on
parle breton et quand on arrive à la
maison pas on se moque nous quand on
parle français
[Musique]
un enfant sur les chemins de la campagne
bretonne c'est devenu aussi rare aussi
surprenant qu'une fleur tardive éclose
au coeur de l'hiver dans les belles
fermes du Trégor dans les villages de
pierre grise au toit d'ardoise noir
vivent désormais de vieux couples isolés
ces couples retardent chaque année le
moment de prendre leur retraite parce
qu'ils ne savent pas à qui transmettre
l'entretien de leur terre ou de leur
petit commerce
[Musique]
un jour Daniel Girodon qui dirige le
Centre Culturel de Lannion à lancer une
idée qui est devenue réalité et qui se
développe avec bonheur il a proposé à
tous les vieux travailleurs solitaires
le secours de jeunes volontaires
volontaire pour aider aux travaux les
plus durs en échange de l'enseignement
précieux celui de la langue bretonne une
langue sur laquelle des étrangers font
des thèses une langue que beaucoup de
jeunes Bretons regrette de ne pas savoir
aussi bien que le français Gilles Roland
Petit garçon de 5 ans va faire ses
commissions à plouzeland chez Monsieur
et Madame Derrien
toujours des des journées
pour aller aider les cultivateurs avec
le Centre culturel pour apprendre le
breton on voudrait faire la même chose
mais alors dans les dans les disons dans
un commerce comme un pouzélande
et on pourrait venir passer une journée
et puis vous pourriez vous en retour on
vous aiderait un petit peu dans votre
travail il y a de la presse et puis en
voiture vous pourriez parler bretons
avec nous on attend bien sûr
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça
ce serait bien écoutez
à l'école il y a plus beaucoup de monde
ici maintenant vous êtes le dernier café
qui reste ici
un plan de travail il y a une maison à
vendre là à côté oui
tout ça quoi c'est bien dommage parce
qu'il y a quelques années il y avait
sûrement beaucoup de monde ici vous
étiez il y avait plein de jeunes autour
et maintenant 216 214
et toute la jeunesse qui est parti quoi
mais oui ils sont partis
comme ça ils sont pas ils n'ont pas
voulu rester il y avait pas de travail
ça fait quel âge maintenant quel âge tu
as maintenant j'ai 71 ans 71 et toi
Pauline
je vous propose de d'organiser quelque
chose quoi c'est à dire que quelques
jeunes pourraient venir une fois le
temps quand il y aura besoin et puis on
comme ça ça vous fera un peu de
compagnie vous vous sentirez moins seul
quoi
plus la solitude tout à fait dans sa
petite maison de Lannion Maria Prat se
souvient de sa jeunesse à la ferme une
époque où toute les générations étaient
mêlées étroitement dans la vie
quotidienne
quand j'étais jeune dans les fermes il y
avait tous les ans faut rester là
jusqu'à leur mariage quoi alors on était
des fois quatre jeunes filles quatre
jeunes gens et tout le monde travaillait
la ferme c'était pas le même travail que
maintenant quoi alors après ça a été ça
change et on a vu des tracteurs qui
change de mode tout c'est à dire la
machine mécanisme touche en général ça
fait que les jeunes restent plus
longtemps à l'école jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à 18 ans pas là après alors il
prend la direction de Paris ou bien dans
les usines mais non oui parce que voilà
les jeunes sont mariés maintenant ils
sont allés juridiques ils sont à Paris
il y a une vingtaine d'années il y a
Paris et maintenant ils sont industrie
ils travaillent dans les usines ou
quelque part ça fait que les jeunes
enfants sont là quoi donc d'aller faire
de moins en moins
dans ces conditions comment conserver
les précieuses traditions bretonnes et
surtout comment les transmettre
ce n'est pas gay pour pour se garer
[Musique]
Gilles Roland le petit garçon que nous
avons suivi tout à l'heure a de la
chance il vit comme autrefois en famille
avec sa sœur Véronique ses parents et
ses grands-parents
[Musique]
sur les chemins son père ira donc à sa
place porter les journaux à la ferme
voisine où vivent Monsieur et Madame
pires ces derniers accueillent souvent
de jeunes volontaires du centre culturel
comme Jean-Pierre aujourd'hui
le batard
et la batteuse alors
grand travail en breton en français
il y a eu le complexe là les jeunes des
parents ont hésité à prendre la moto à
leurs enfants voilà oui vous pouvez pas
la montre quoi on pouvait pas l'utiliser
dans les écoles et puis c'est ça c'était
une langue de plouc c'est ça
c'est un peu ce qu'on disait dans le
temps ouais
à l'école
en récréation on avait pas le droit non
on mettait le symbole autour du cou à ce
qu'il parlait non on donne un bouchon ou
une patate une patate
au début nous mettait tout au piquet et
quand on parle les breton et quand on
arrive à la maison enfin on se moque
nous quand on parle les Français
nous quand on parle français et
maintenant il y a une réaction comme
parmi les jeunes il y a beaucoup de
jeunes qui veulent apprendre leur langue
la langue bretonne oui mais non ça va
travailler dans les fermes quoi à droite
et à gauche
il y a pas mal de ferme dans le coin qui
accueille des jeunes comme ça pour
apprendre la langue ici
il y a eu deux ou trois ou quatre même
dans les champs dans le travail
autour des bêtes il faisait tout changer
le fumier envoyez les vaches dehors et
les rentrer il y a très et
arracher les betteraves arracher les
pommes de terre ramasser enfin tout ce
qu'il y avait à faire dans la ferme
[Musique]
mais ces jeunes là qui viennent de la
ville ça te pose pas trop de problèmes
d'une part pour apprendre le breton et
puis autrement pour les héberger pour la
nourriture par exemple ou bien pour
faire les travaux disons quoi c'est pas
tellement gênant disons au contraire ça
nous arrange oui
et vous voulez apprendre le but tombe
comme ça il voulait s'appliquer à la
ferme de peur qui se renvoyer peut-être
ah voilà oui
il y a pas de chance qu'il serait envoyé
[Musique]
depuis longtemps
le dictionnaire
elle ne s'est jamais mariée il n'y a
pourtant personne de plus entouré
qu'elle depuis qu'elle s'est installée à
Lannion les Santa son frère la ferme
familiale l'organisation des veillées
bretonnes remplissent sa vie d'éveiller
qui font la joie des autres et la sienne
tu parles un peu trop vite
on a eu l'idée pour sauver la langue
bretonne et pour distter sur tous les
gens de la campagne on s'est dit
pourquoi ne pas former une équipe pour
aller le samedi soir pendant l'hiver
dans les Bulgares et les salles de fêtes
là alors on a cherché des musiciens des
chanteurs des compteurs on a écrit des
pièces et alors depuis voilà il y a 18
ans que ça dure mais ça me donne
énormément d'occupations et de travail
il reste tous temps qu'ils peuvent mais
voilà il arrive la raison de soit se
marier soit de déménage soit le service
militaire quand ils ont des réseaux ils
ne quitte pour des raisons valentes vous
savez que la chaîne du galérien qui se
trouve à la chapelle là-bas m'intrigue
depuis longtemps alors j'ai voulu cette
fois-ci puis demander un drame pour la
première fois depuis 18 ans qu'on joue
préparez un drame alors j'ai donc copié
le rôle je pense que ça va vous plaire
vu dans les ou presque 12
je copie les rôles pour chacun et après
alors pendant la séance mais dans les
coulisses une clé mon cahier et alors si
quelqu'un est bien franche je suis là
pour le dépanner
puis pour aider à monter la scène et
tout en place bien sûr je dois connaître
quand même ce que ce qu'on doit faire
c'est naturel que ce soit au courant de
tout ça vous écrivez en pensant à eux ah
oui toujours quand j'écris la pièce il
retient voilà un rôle qui convient d'un
tel ou à une telle et alors je fais ça
un peu de vert son genre dans ces
conditions est-ce que c'est difficile de
vieillir de les lire de vieillir
on ne sent pas nous serons pas compte
avec les jeunes je crois qu'on reste
aussi jeune un peu
et alors
surtout ne s'ennuie pas
je sais pas ce que c'est
[Musique]